-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
Yeah, you're here.
You made it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
It is the holiday season.
Isn't it a great time
to be here in New York City?
Doesn't it feel good?
[ Cheers and applause ]
But I just saw that the police
just warned tourists
to be on the lookout
for pickpockets.
And to everyone in the audience
who just checked your pockets,
it's too late now.
[ Laughter ]
You can never be too safe.
That's why this time of year,
instead of a wallet,
I keep all my money in crypto.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
Pickpockets are everywhere.
'Cause nothing ruins a week
of $200 Broadway tickets
and $12 pretzels
like getting ripped off.
You know what I'm saying?
Hey, here's some good news
for the holidays.
After more than a year
of record inflation,
it looks like prices
are finally starting to go down.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. So...
So, take that, annoying people
who finished all their
Christmas shopping in November.
Ha ha!
We win!
Some political news.
Tomorrow is
the Georgia Senate runoff
between Herschel Walker
and Senator Raphael Warnock.
Warnock's supporters said
that they're voting for him
because of his policies,
while Walker's supporters say
they're voting for him
because it's funny.
[ Laughter ]
More than 1.8 million Georgia
residents have already voted,
and that's just
Herschel Walker's children.
[ Audience oohs ]
Right now --
[ Applause ]
-Whoa!
-Right now,
Warnock is leading Walker
in the polls by about 4 points.
Yeah, only 4 points.
That explains
Warnock's slogan...
It's like -- It's only 4 points.
Tomorrow is the big runoff
between Herschel Walker
and Raphael Warnock.
And I must say,
it's nice to see two candidates
set aside their personal attacks
and focus on real issues
in their campaign.
Check out this ad
for Herschel Walker.
-Herschel Walker
has always let Georgians know
where he stands
on the important issues
like taxes, jobs...
and vampires.
-[ Hissing ]
-I don't know if you know.
Vampires are some cool people,
are they not?
But I'm-a tell you something
today I found out.
A werewolf can kill a vampire.
Do you know that?
-Where does Raphael Warnock
stand on vampires?
He's never told us.
But Herschel Walker has.
-Because, you know,
gotta have a stake
and gotta have a thing
that kill 'em in the heart.
And you got a necklace of
garlic, 'cause that work.
I don't know what it does,
but it work.
Gotta have a cross 'cause
it burns. I know that works.
-So I don't want to be
a vampire anymore.
I want to be a werewolf.
[ Wolf howls ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well, everyone's
talking about this.
Over the weekend,
former President Trump
called for the 2020 election
to be overturned
by terminating the Constitution.
[ Audience oohs ]
And Trump can actually do it
because he has the real
Constitution hanging in
the bathroom at Mar-a-Lago.
[ Laughter ]
So he could...
Trump wants to terminate
the Constitution.
Then a staffer held a brick
to his ear like,
"Yeah, working on it
right now, sir. Yeah."
Well, listen to this.
I read that compared
to past presidents,
books about President Biden
aren't selling many copies.
Yeah, you can tell that Biden
books aren't that exciting.
I mean, just look
at the blurbs on the back.
For instance, this critic from
"The New York Times" wrote...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up,
"The Washington Post" wrote...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Then "USA Today" wrote...
-Wow!
-These are the blurbs
on the back of --
on the back of the book
that real humans wrote. Wow.
-Yeah. Yeah.
"Time" Magazine wrote...
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally,
the "Chicago Tribune" wrote...
I mean, why would you put that
on the back of the --
-Wow.
[ Applause ]
-Some entertainment news.
A new episode of "White Lotus"
dropped last night,
and it was a real doozy.
-Oh, no. No spoilers.
I haven't seen it yet.
-Oh, I wasn't
gonna spoil anything.
I was just saying
it was a good episode. I --
-I don't care.
I might be able
to extrapolate information
from what you say.
-I don't see
how that's possible.
-Just don't. Okay?
-Alright. Fine.
What else can we talk about?
Everyone's talking
about the show "Wednesday" --
-Ah, wah-wah-wah! No spoilers.
-I was just gonna say the dance
scene is getting a lot of buzz.
-Great, Jimmy. Now I know
there's a dance scene.
-Everyone knows
It's huge on TikTok.
-Great!
Now I know it was huge
on TikTok!
-Alright. Fine. What else
is there to talk about?
"Yellowstone" is big right now.
-Ahh-- I haven't seen it.
-"Violent Night"
is getting good reviews.
-Haven't seen it.
-The trailer for "Cocaine Bear."
-♪ La dee da dee da da da ♪
-The "Survivor" finale is --
-♪ Loo loo loo loo,
loo loo loo loo loo ♪
-Alright. Fine. Fine. We'll talk
about the news instead.
Alright? Everyone knows the U.S.
lost to the Netherlands.
-In what?
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-President Joe Biden --
-He won the election?
[ Laughter ]
-Donald Trump --
-He won the election?!
-Christmas is almost here.
-It is?
-Alright. That's enough.
You're behind on everything.
What have you been doing
this whole time?
-Wordle. I'm actually doing
today's puzzle right now.
-Well, get a load of this.
It's actually woken.
W-O-K-E-N.
"Woken" is the word today.
-I swear to God.
Mother [bleep]!
-Hey, hey, hey! Hey, hey!
Come on, man! Whoa! Hey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Sorry!
Unbelievable. Sorry!
-Steve: Wow.
-Guys, get this.
Following a pause
during the pandemic,
the Catholic Church
has reintroduced handshakes
during mass.
-[ Applause ]
-[ Woman exclaims ]
-Really?
-Wow.
-Peace be with you. Wow.
-Yep, shaking hands at church,
or as Mike Pence calls it,
"going all the way."
[ Laughter ]
Hey. Did you guys see this?
Everyone's been using
this new A.I. app
that takes your selfies
and turns them
into beautiful portraits.
I did mine earlier today.
Look at -- Look at mine.
They made me look like a...
1930s Hollywood star.
-Oh.
-Quest, did you try it?
-Yeah, I did.
Check it out, man.
-Ooh.
-See?
That's what I look like
as an impressionist painting.
-Yeah, I love that.
Higgins, did you try it?
-Yeah. Take a look.
-Hey! God!
What filter is that?!
-Filter?
That was Saturday.
-Oh, my God!
Moving on.
[ Clears throat ]
Hey, guys, I heard about a
tattoo removal studio in London
that's lasering off
Kanye West tattoos for free.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's great. You just walk in
and say, "Make my Ye a nay."
♪♪
For the first time
in three years,
office holiday parties are back.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yep, it's that magical night
when you say,
"let's not talk about work"
and then only talk about work.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it's the same
conversations you have at work,
but now they're an inch
from your ear
and 10 times the volume.
-[ Loud music plays ]
-"I'm thinking about following
up with Brian about that raise!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Music stops ]
That's right. The party is
basically this meme,
plus Santa hats.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, every office holiday party
is the same.
They all start
with a champagne toast
and end with half the staff
updating their LinkedIn.
The White House chief of staff
said that he expects
President Biden to announce that
he's running for re-election
after the holidays.
That makes sense.
Most Americans announce that
they're gonna start running
after the holidays.
[ Laughter ]
Also, I'm no political expert,
but if you announce that
you're going to make
an announcement,
isn't that the announcement?
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of running for
president, new polling shows
that in a potential 2024
matchup, Biden is tied with
Florida governor Ron DeSantis,
while DeSantis leads former
president Trump by 10 points.
-Ooh.
-Yep, Biden, DeSantis,
and Trump -- it's like your
grandfather, your crazy uncle,
and the family member
nobody talks about anymore.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Trump's unfavorable rating
has surged to 67%.
To give you an idea of how bad
that is, Kanye is only at 66.
[ Laughter ]
Bad.
Some more 2024 news -- former
Trump national security adviser
John Bolton said that
he's considering running
for president.
He's even been testing out
some campaign slogans
to see what people respond to.
Check these out.
First there's...
[ Laughter ]
Then there's...
-Oh!
-[ Laughter ]
-And finally, there's...
[ Laughter ]
"Anything!
You'll never get it from me!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right, John Bolton said
that he's considering
a 2024 presidential run
to challenge Trump.
Can we see Bolton?
There he is.
Yeah, well, he --
He already has
a fair amount of support.
Check out what some of
his supporters are saying.
First up, Geraldo Rivera said...
Then actor Sam Elliott said...
[ Laughter ]
And singer David Crosby said...
Then Hulk Hogan said...
[ Laughter ]
Then the Monopoly Man said...
[ Cheers and applause ]
And finally, the Lorax said...
[ Laughter ]
Can't help it.
Did you guys see this?
This is real.
During a hearing, Rudy Giuliani
was caught on a hot mike telling
his lawyer that he accidentally
wore two watches.
[ Laughter ]
Now, the quality of the footage
is bad,
but it doesn't disappoint.
Check this out.
-So, I'm at a good place
to stop, Mr. Chair.
-Thank you.
You know I have two watches on?
[ Laughter ]
-What?
-Just a reminder, that was
Trump's top lawyer.
[ Laughter ]
Two watches.
-Ah.
-Oh, this is very cool.
Researchers in Germany have
developed Golfi,
a golfing robot that can make
perfect putts.
-Hmm.
-Yeah. And that's not all.
Here's a full list of
what Golfi can do.
It can, of course, play golf,
or it can put his hand
on your shoulder.
It can say,
"I'm proud of you, son."
[ Laughter ]
And it can kiss your mom.
Wait, kiss your mom?
Yup. Now Golfi's moving in.
He's calling you "champ"
and showing up to
your baseball games.
"Great catch, kid,
but you really
should have thrown to third."
"Shut up!
You're not my real dad!"
"Yes, I am. Why do you think
you have robot legs?"
Look down.
Oh, God, you do have robot legs.
Robot arms, robot face.
He's right. You're not human.
You're Golfi Jr.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, here's some good news.
I saw that the head of the CDC
said the updated flu vaccine
looks like a very good match
for this year's strains.
Basically the vaccine saw
the strains
and was like, "Swipe right."
[ Laughter ]
It's not a perfect match,
but like most people, the flu is
just happy to go home with
someone for the holidays.
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys, get this.
"Dahmer" just became
the third show on Netflix
to hit 1 billion hours
viewed in 60 days.
-Wow!
-And if someone mentions that
at the office holiday party,
do not split an Uber home.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Guys, we're right in the middle
of the holiday season.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Do you feel the vibes?
And if you're waiting to buy
a Christmas tree,
you better hurry, because due to
high demand and low supply,
prices are soaring.
Yeah.
I'm trying to get ahead of this.
That's why every night,
on the way home,
I cut one branch off
the Rockefeller Center
Christmas Tree.
I just take it away from there.
I'm getting there.
♪ Christmastime ♪
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it's the holiday season,
and today, New York
got an early Christmas gift.
Aaron Judge is coming back
to the Yankees!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes!
That's right.
Yankees superstar Aaron Judge
has decided to stay in New York,
agreeing to a nine-year,
$360 million contract.
[ Cheers and applause ]
When he heard that,
Babe Ruth said, "What the hell?
I got paid in peanuts and
Cracker Jacks."
[ Laughter ]
$360 million.
Today, Judge walked into
the owner's office and said,
"You're in my seat."
[ Laughter ]
What a deal.
Aaron is now the only person
who can afford a beer
in Yankee Stadium.
-Oh!
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's true.
The good news is,
Judge got $360 million.
The bad news is,
the rest of the team
is now getting paid in crypto.
[ Laughter ]
Did you guys hear about this?
Apparently, former president
Trump's lawyers
just turned over more
classified items to the FBI
after finding them at
Trump's storage unit in Florida.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, we were just
a week away from
our most classified secrets
ending up on
an episode of "Storage Wars."
[ Laughter and applause ]
I mean, really.
[ Cheers and applause ]
A storage unit.
You know that you've stolen
too many top secret documents
when you can't even fit them
all in your house.
You know what I'm saying?
Meanwhile, last night, Trump
hosted an event at Mar-a-Lago
that featured a prominent
QAnon conspiracy theorist.
It's not good when you mingle
with a conspiracy theorist
to distract from your dinner
with a white supremacist.
You know what I'm saying?
Hey, guys, get this --
airline passengers in Europe
will soon be allowed
to use 5G service
to make phone calls on board.
The only thing worse than your
seatmate trying to talk to you
is your seatmate
trying to talk to someone else.
It's like,
"Hey, can you hear me?!
I'm on a plane right now!"
Yeah, this means no more putting
your phone on airplane mode.
Yep, everyone's like, "Finally,
we can stop pretending
to do that."
[ Laughter ]
Good.
Some entertainment news.
"Wednesday" is on track
to become Netflix's
most-watched English-language
TV series ever.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know these
are crazy times when a show
about a depressed goth child is
what makes us all happy.
[ Laughter ]
I mean...
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's good, it's good.
Everyone's talking about
the holiday action movie
"Violent Night," as well.
It did surprisingly well
at the box office,
so they're re-editing
old holiday favorites now
to capitalize on this new trend.
-Really?
-Look at this ad I saw today.
-They tried to take
everything he had,
but this Christmas,
George Bailey fights back.
He's smooth-talking,
hard-drinking,
and he's got a message
for anyone who crosses him.
-You're going to die!
-[ Screams ]
-Every time a bell rings,
George kicks some ass.
-Where's that money,
you stupid old [bleep]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
-Wow!
"Stupid old --" beep!
-"Where's that money at?"
Right now, a lot of people are
putting out holiday decorations.
I saw one homeowner
in Wisconsin --
this made me laugh --
who kept it very simple.
Look at this video.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
That's fantastic.
That's the most effort someone's
ever put into no effort.
♪♪
Well, I'm in
a good mood right now
because we're right in
the middle of
the holiday season right now,
and I love the holiday season.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love it.
By the way, here's a little tip
for anyone buying presents.
Whatever you buy,
just say you got it on Etsy
so everyone thinks a lot of
thought went into it.
That's what I do.
Of course, gift cards
are always a popular option.
And I like
the Amazon gift cards,
because they basically say,
"The only thing
I 100% know about you
is that you want a gift."
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, I saw that tomorrow
is National Christmas Card Day.
And I've already seen some
pretty interesting cards
this year.
I'll show you some of the
ones I've got.
For instance, look at this.
This is a card from Aaron Judge.
On the front, it says...
Open it up, and it says...
You go, "Wait. Come on."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Here's another one I got.
-They're very specific, yeah.
-Here's a card from
"Good Morning America."
It says...
You open it up, it says...
[ Laughter ]
-Wow!
-I don't know what it means.
-Morning.
-Here's a card from Joe Biden.
It says...
You open it up, it says...
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Wow.
Here's a nice card
I got from Elon Musk.
It says...
Open it up, it says...
-Wow!
-That's nice.
Here's a card from
Herschel Walker. It says...
Open it up, it says...
And you know what?
He's trying.
[ Laughter ]
-He's trying.
He falls down, he gets back up.
-Yeah.
And, finally, here's a card
from Vice President Harris.
It says...
Open it up, it says...
Everyone's in the spirit.
Very nice.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's get to some news.
Everybody's talking about this.
Today, 10 months after
she was detained,
Brittney Griner
was freed from Russian custody
in a prisoner exchange...
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
...between The White House
and the Kremlin.
You could tell Biden
was fired up
when he began his speech with,
"It's Brittney [bleep]"
And you go, "Hey."
[ Laughter ]
Putin is no stranger
to prisoner swaps.
In fact, "Prisoner Swap"
is the most popular
reality show in Russia.
Yeah, there was a prisoner swap.
In exchange for Griner,
Moscow received
the notorious Russian
arms dealer
who is known as
"The Merchant of Death."
-Ooh!
-Can we see what he looks like?
[ Laughter ]
-When asked for a statement,
he said,
"If your wife has ever said,
'Come move these
rocket launchers
so I can take a bath,'
you might be
an international arms dealer."
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Hey, I read that the C.E.O.
of Build-A-Bear Workshop
said 40% of their shoppers are
now teenagers and adults.
It's little surprising,
but it does explain
the new ad campaign.
Check this out.
-At Build-A-Bear Workshop,
we're not just for kids.
We're for kids of all ages,
so the next time
you're at the mall,
stop on by and build a bear.
Build a bestie.
Build a boss.
Build a boyfriend.
Build a better life,
the one you used to dream about
back when everything
still felt exciting and vital,
because age is nothing
but a number,
a big, terrible number,
a grandfather clock
about to strike,
the sound of whose
bong, bong, bong
will never be heard by
the lifeless bear
you clutch to as a totem of
what was once possible
but no longer is.
Build-A-Bear Workshop --
we're going
through something right now.
-Wow!
-That explains it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
-Well, guys,
"Avatar: The Way of Water"
finally comes out next week.
A lot of people are
excited for it.
It's getting great reviews.
But since it's been
almost exactly 13 years
since "Avatar" came out,
we thought it'd be helpful
to recap what happened
in the first movie.
So here now with a rap recap
is Tariq from The Roots.
Take it away, Tariq.
-One, two, three.
-♪ I said, I don't remember ♪
[ Music stops ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-I heard about a man in Florida
who was arrested for
allegedly stealing over
$1,300 worth of
toothbrushes from Walgreens.
Yep, the man was convicted after
four out of five jurors
found him guilty.
♪♪
Guys, it's that time of year.
Tomorrow is SantaCon...
[ Audience laughs, groans ]
...here in New York City.
[ Laughter ]
You already know what it is.
Yeah, at SantaCon, thousands of
people will dress up as Santa
and pack the streets
for an all-day bar crawl.
So, before you go to bed,
make sure you put out
a plate of Advil
and a tall glass of Pedialyte.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, happy SantaCon.
To everyone in their 20s,
have fun.
To everyone in their 30s,
it's getting kind of sad.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, get this,
according to a new survey,
30% of Americans
have injured themselves
during holiday-related
activities.
While the other 70% are the ones
filming it for TikTok.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, 30% get injured.
Who knew climbing a ladder
and hanging lights
on an icy gutter
could be dangerous?
[ Laughter ]
Actually, the most common injury
is spraining your face
from fake smiling
after opening a present.
[ Laughter ]
"It's a Slanket.
Oh, cool.
I -- I'll google it,
and I love it."
Speaking of the holidays,
this weekend
First Lady Jill Biden
will give a tour
of the White House
holiday decorations
for an HGTV Christmas special.
Yeah, and after that, stay tuned
for Melania's
decoration special,
"The Nightmare
Before Christmas."
[ Laughter ]
Let's get to some news.
I saw a new poll
that said President Biden's
approval rating
is now up to 46%.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
46%, that's pretty much
the blood-alcohol content
of everyone at SantaCon.
[ Laughter ]
I like that we're cool
with 46% for a president,
but if a restaurant
had 2 1/2 stars on Yelp,
we'd call
the health department.
[ Laughter ]
Did you guys see this?
A top adviser
to Senator Bernie Sanders
said that if Biden
doesn't run in 2024,
Sanders will give it
a hard look.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, people weren't sure
about him
the last two elections,
but maybe they'll vote for him
now that he's more mature.
[ Laughter ]
Some more big news
from Washington.
Today, Senator Kyrsten Sinema
announced
that she's leaving
the Democratic Party
and registering
as an Independent.
It's good timing, 'cause
nothing says the holiday season
like leaving a party early.
Right?
[ Laughter ]
Well, listen to this.
I heard that if Putin loses
the war in Ukraine,
he's going to flee
to South America.
Yeah, and he has his disguise
all planned out.
He's gonna wear a shirt.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you.
[ Rim shot ]
Some business news --
Apple has a new iMessage feature
that will alert both users
if they were being spied on
by a state-sponsored attacker.
Yeah, it's never good seeing
"North Korea
has entered the chat."
And you go...
[ Laughter ]
Some entertainment news.
I read that the
Miss Universe Pageant is moving
from broadcast TV to streaming
on the Roku Channel.
Yep, and now the winner
of the talent portion
is whoever can find
the Roku Channel.
[ Laughter ]
When asked how
they felt about it,
a representative for the pageant
said, "World peace."
[ Laughter ]
Guys, last night in L.A.,
there was a big
video-game award show
called The Game Awards, okay?
And they got a pretty huge actor
to present.
Take a look at this.
-Please join me in welcoming
to the Game Awards, Al Pacino.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-But, uh, I -- I -- I --
I'm -- It's hard for me
to see the teleprompter.
[ Laughter ]
I don't play
a whole lot of video games.
[ Laughter ]
[ Rim shot ]
-Wha-- Wha-- What?
[ Laughter continues ]
-It was Pacino's
most challenging role yet,
"guy who wants to be here."
[ Laughter ]
I don't know if he
played "Super Mario Bros.,"
but he definitely
ate a mushroom.
[ Laughter ]
Once the mushrooms
wear off, he's like,
"Say hello
to my little friend."
[ Mario shrinking sound ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Thank you.
I do space work.
-Yeah, wow, space work,
very good.
-Hey, this is going viral.
A man, who was out kayaking,
saw a great white shark.
Yeah, and then, when he asked
his friend what he should do,
his friend had
a very interesting response.
Watch this.
-Dude, Danny.
-Yeah.
-What do I do?
Holy [bleep]
-Film it.
-Holy [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
-Honestly, at that point,
what else can you really do,
I guess?
He was like, "Uh, now slap it
with a tortilla!"
[ Laughter ]
"Slap the shark
with a tortilla!"
And finally, a puppy was found
after he escaped from his home
in Manhattan and swam across
the Hudson River to New Jersey.
He swam all the way
to New Jersey
just to get away from SantaCon.